[music playing]
NARRATOR: Southeast Asia.
Every year during the 9th lunar
month of the Chinese calendar,
thousands of Taoists
throughout the region
celebrate a 2000-year-old
tradition called
the Nine Emperor Gods Festival.
The Nine Emperor Gods Festival
is a very, very important
festival in southeast
Asian Chinese communities,
and it revolves around a
carnival like ritual that
takes place for nine full days.
The point of this festival is to
summon the very, very powerful
nine emperor gods,
because they're seen
as residing up in the skies.
NARRATOR: The nine sky lords
are believed by Taoists
to have been the
original rulers of China
and the offspring of the
supreme god of creation.
According to legend,
the nine emperor gods
come from the nine
stars that make up
the Big Dipper, seven
of which are visible
and two that are invisible.
They are tasked with
controlling the universe
and keeping order on Earth.
There is this belief in Taoism
and Chinese culture in general
that the supernatural
world takes
the shape of a
bureaucratic empire,
and there is a very
detailed hierarchy
with ranks and bureaus.
And the fact that these are
known as the nine emperor gods
show that are very
high ranking gods
in this celestial
bureaucracy, and that they
do have a very
important function
of governing basically
the celestial realm,
but also the human realm.
NARRATOR: In order to
assure the will of the gods
is honored for the upcoming
year, select devotees channel
and even embody the nine
emperor gods during the festival
processions.
There are typically about
nine spirit mediums who
enter a trance and then channel
these gods to bring them down
and to keep them very
content and happy.
The reason why it's
crucial to keep them happy
is because they keep
an account, a record,
of everything that
happens on Earth.
They control human destiny.
At the end of the nine days,
when the festival reaches
its climax, the gods
eventually return to the stars
from which they came.
NARRATOR: Curiously, this
idea of nine gods or overlords
watching over earth can
be found in cultures
throughout the world.
The Aztecs of Mesoamerica were
known to worship nine gods
called the Lords of the Night.
In the Norse tradition, nine
gods survived the Ragnarok,
or earthly destruction.
According to Buddhist
legend, the emperor Ashoka
consulted with a
secret society called
the Nine Unknown Men,
who were said to possess
the knowledge of the universe.
The ancient Etruscans
of Italy also
believed in nine gods that
could be persuaded to influence
the fate of mankind.
And in Greek mythology, Zeus
led a council of nine gods
created to oversee humanity.
The canonical Olympian gods
are imagined to be about 12,
and they have a sort of
governing body as well,
and so they have a council.
For the most part, the nine
most important gods are there.
Sitting at the top
of that is Zeus.
These make up sort of the
power structure of the heavens,
and they occasionally meet
to determine what they're
going to do about mankind.
Zeus created the
Council of Nine
and this was Aphrodite, Apollo,
Athena, Diameter, Hephaestus,
Hera, Hermes, Poseidon,
and Zeus himself,
and these are the gods that
then could interact with humans
I guess to keep us in line.